How's it going everyone? In this video,
we are going to talk about why your
continuations are failing. We will walk
through a few different scenarios of why
continuations fail, how to correct
those, and what to watch out for. So,
let's get into the PDF. Now the first
thing you need to understand when
looking for a continuation is what is
the ideal scenario that you are looking
for. What do you want to see on the
charts when seeking an entry? Now
ideally we want to see a nice aggressive
V-shaped reversal. So when price reaches
into a fair value gap or sweeps out a
low, we have a nice V-shaped or quick
recovery back up into the range closing
through the series of downclo candles
and vice versa for the bearish scenario.
This aggressive recovery or swift price
action through the opening price shows
us that price has the intent to move
higher. This is a continuation that we
can trust to trade higher. Now, let's
get into the first scenario on why your
continuation is failing. When price
doesn't get that nice V-shaped recovery
and close over the series of downlosed
candles or fails to change the state of
delivery is when price is forming a
consolidation, then price will go ahead
and close over that level. But what
happens? It fails. Now, why does it
fail? Well, when you take a look, this
is actually a consolidation. And this
closure through which you think is
validating this low is actually a
manipulation of this consolidation range
and then it looks to trade to the other
side. So, how can we look to avoid this
scenario in our trading? Well, when we
see that price is failing to form that
ideal continuation and consolidating
when price closes over, we want to wait
to see what happens next. Do we have
price form a new continuation off of
that high or essentially breaking out of
the range or does it fail and go back
across the range? So step one is to wait
to see this next candle and how it
reacts. Does it form a new continuation
in which case I can trade that higher or
does it fail and go across the range? If
it fails and goes across the range, well
then I can look to trade this swing
point off of this low as we are
manipulating the lows to go higher. So
now that we have covered reason number
one, what is reason number two? Reason
number two is the continuation forms at
the same time that we are taking out
highs in a range or a short-term target
is taken. So here you can see we have a
sweep of a low. We have a nice closure
through the series of downclosed candles
sweeping out that low forming a
continuation or a protected swing. But
at the same time we are sweeping out the
highs. This can a lot of times cause
price to form a reversal or a new phase
of price and then go run out your
stop-loss. So, similarly to scenario
number one or reason number one, what
are we going to wait for? We're just
going to wait for extra confirmation,
another continuation. After taking out
this short-term high, do we form a
continuation respecting this fair value
gap or the opposing candles? Here we do,
and we can trade that higher. Here you
can see we do not respect those opposing
candles and we run out the low. If I am
still bullish, well then I'm just going
to use this as my new point of interest.
As this is a consolidation range, we've
taken out the highs, we've taken out the
lows. Once we form a nice V-shaped
recovery in an ideal continuation, then
I can look to get on side with it. Now,
what is reason number three? Reason
number three is a higher time frame
target has already been taken. So, let's
say for instance, we have previous days
highs lined up here as failure swings.
We go ahead and we run into that higher
time frame target. There are a lot of
people that feel FOMO from missing this
move. They go ahead and see a new
continuation and then they look to enter
it and they get stopped out. Now, you
have to realize when we hit a higher
time frame target, that is when we can
form a new phase of price. So, you can
see here, not only are we at a higher
time frame target, we're forming that
continuation while taking out a previous
high. And this is actually setting up a
bearish change in the state of delivery.
So, I simply just want to avoid this
scenario. Realize that you are going to
miss some moves and it's not the end of
the world. Live to trade another day. So
those are the three different scenarios
on why your continuations are failing.
Let's get into trading view and we'll go
over a few examples of these. So here we
are in Trading View and let's first look
at what an ideal continuation looks
like. Now, ideally, we are going to have
it where we have a point of interest, a
reach into that point of interest, a
nice V-shaped recovery, and quickly
closing over those down close or up
close candles. So, if you notice here,
we have a nice leg up, a expansion, and
then we are looking to see if we get a
retracement, a reversal or a
consolidation. And here you can see we
have a move lower. So, is this a
reversal or a retracement? Well, we get
told that by this next candle. And this
is ideally what you want to see out of a
continuation or the formation of a
retracement. We have a reach into that
fair value gap or that point of interest
and we have a nice V-shaped recovery
closing over those down close candles.
What does that do? That then protects
this low right here. And we can
anticipate if price is going to continue
this trend, it should go higher. Now
also you notice how it has yet to take
out this high. If we have price when it
takes out a high, we want to see a
closure through that high. And we'll
talk about that in future scenarios. But
as we let this continue, you can see we
get a nice retest and expanding higher.
Now you can see we have expansion. If we
expect this low to hold, then what do we
need to see hold? Well, we'd want to see
this CISD hold or this fair value gap
here. Here you can see this is an ideal
formation as we're forming a swing point
and also forming a protected swing. So
that's a nice V-shaped recovery. And
this is also ideal as we have not taken
out our previous high and we can get
another expansion higher. So this is
ideally what I want to see out of
continuations. But like you guys know,
they're not always that perfect, right?
They're not always going to have a clean
point of interest, a nice clean close
over. And we're going to talk about a
few scenarios where they aren't that
clean. So here we have a nice V-shaped
reversal. And if I was looking for a
continuation, we have a fair value gap
right here. And what would I be looking
for? a closure through this down close
candle. Now, I use a singular candle in
this case because there's not more than
one candle. Let's see if we get a
closure through that level.
And you can see here we do get that
closure through this level. But what do
we notice? You see how we didn't get the
closure through in a nice Vshape right
here where we don't have a swift price
action to close over and continue. This
is showing that it is forming a
consolidation. When price does go close
over this level here, what is it also
doing? It's actually just sweeping out
the high in the consolidation range to
do what? Go and trade lower. So, you
notice how it's taking out the high and
now we're just in a range and it can go
ahead and trade lower and that is how we
save ourselves from a loss because
instead of looking to try to trade this
as a continuation, we identify that it
is consolidation and we can stay
sidelined, right? And that's how we save
ourselves from these type of losses. So,
let's take a look at this continuation
here. We have expansion up and we
retrace into a fair value gap. But where
are we looking to determine if we have a
continuation the series of downcloed
candles into that important level? Let's
see if we get a closure through that
level.
And you can see we cannot close above
this here. So what is this turning into?
This is now turning into a consolidation
in which this isn't a retracement
anymore. This is a consolidation and
then we'd be focused on the highs and
the lows of the range. Instead of
anticipating this low to hold, this
becomes an entry point or where you're
looking for price to reach into, in
which case you can look for an entry or
save yourself from a loss. And here you
can see now we're just consolidating
pretty clearly.
And why would you not anticipate this to
be a continuation? Well, we're just
inside a range, right? So, this is how
it's going to save you from some losses
because you're not interested in
closures over this level or any closures
over down close candles in here because
you identify it as a consolidation
instead of looking long. It saves you
from a loss and you're not going to get
caught in this loss down here. So, this
is reason number one and this is an
example of where it just keeps you from
taking a loss. But now you know what
reason number one looks like and it's
forming a consolidation. How do we
actually get on side with something like
this? And there are two ways. We can
either trade the breakout with a
continuation or wait for a new
manipulation. So here you can see we
have a bullish trend. We have a point of
interest. Let's see if we get a
continuation in here. And you can see
what do we see? A series of downlosed
candles. We can't go close back over
that level. That levels used as the
point of interest to trade back lower.
Now we have made a new low into a fair
value up. We have a new series of
downclo candles. Let's see if we get a
nice V-shaped reversal back over this
one. And you can see how long it's
taking to return up. Two candles down
and we have six candles up and we can't
even get back to this level. That is not
fast or V-shaped. So, let's see what
happens. We don't go close over this
level. But even if we did close over
this level at that point, what is this?
This is just a big consolidation range.
So, if we are bullish, we are no longer
looking for this level. We're looking at
it as a consolidation. in which case
we're using the low as a point of
interest looking for a manipulation.
So why would I not care about this
manipulation right here in this
continuation? That's just internal to
the range and you're trading a
consolidation. You want to avoid that.
So let's see what happens
right here. Even if we got a closure
over, would we be interested in that?
No, because it does not reach our point
of interest. Now we sweep out the low.
Now we can look to see if we form a
continuation. So, what are we wanting to
see? A nice V-shaped reversal that
recovers and then closes over this.
And you can see how we get a pretty
swift closure over. It only takes a
couple candles. Now, I prefer 1 2 maybe
three. If it takes longer than that, a
lot of times it's just taking too long.
So, now we have a reversal. We have a
low we can trust. So, that is expected
to be a continuation of this higher time
frame trend. We could also look for
another continuation to form.
And here you can see we run out highs.
So this is getting into scenario two
where we run out short-term highs. Am I
going to want to long at these highs?
No. I'm going to want to wait for a new
phase of price and a new continuation to
form. What do we have here? We reach
into a fair value gap and then we want
to see what a nice swift fast closure
through this area, right? because that
is going to tell us we've formed a
continuation and we can trade higher
which there we go and do if we go ahead
and follow this let's see what happens
here we reach lower is this a
continuation I would consider personally
no because we don't reach into a point
of interest now if you use correlated
assets and we have an SMT here sure you
can use that but I would not consider
that because we don't have a point of
interest so this is just an example of
being patient right when we have that
consolidation wait for the manipulation
if If we break out through the highs,
wait for a continuation to make sure
that this is not a reversal to trade it
the other way. So, here we are with
another example. You can see we have a
nice aggressive move higher and then a
consolidation. So, if we see a
consolidation and we're looking for a
continuation, what do we want to see? We
either want to see a manipulation of the
low or a breakout of the high. So, we're
not going to trade the breakout unless
we have a continuation. Let's see what
happens here. We trade into the high. Am
I going to trust this? No, because we
could just as easily form a move to the
downside and then back up, right? I need
to see a continuation or a new swing
point form off of these highs. So, what
do we have? Price reaching lower reaches
into a point of interest or this swing
point. Now, do we get a closure through
this level? Let's see. And you can see
we do. And you see how that is quick,
right? We have a nice move lower,
shallow, and slow. Nice closure over.
You can see we are taking out this
short-term high. So if I trust this, I
could just take an entry like this right
on the closure through my stop there. If
I don't, as I'm taking out this little
high here, I can see if we get a
continuation move, right? If I want more
confirmation, you can always demand
more. Right? Do we reach into this?
No, we do not. Right? So that does
lacking the point of interest here. So
this would not be a valid continuation
for me. So if I did trust it, I could
get on side here. There was no further
continuation for this move to the upside
there. But does that make sense on how
to trade a consolidation? If I'm trading
a consolidation and a breakout, I'm
trading the failure to manipulate this
level. I can't form a manipulation to
trade the other way. So, I can trade it
to the upside. So, in this next example,
what do we have? We have some failure
swings on the high here. We have a nice
V-shaped reversal, right? And then we'd
be looking for continuations.
One thing you note is when we have this
candle that doesn't form a swing,
generally I ignore it. So a lot of times
I'm not going to use this lower candle,
I'm going to use this as the
continuation. So here you can see I
could be looking for a continuation
higher. I want to see if we can get a
closure over this level here. Let's see
what happens. And what do we notice?
This candle not only closes over, it
takes out this high as well as all the
highs on the left here. So, this is what
I'm talking about when I'm saying price
is taking out short-term highs. It can
be this high, but when it's more
significant highs like buyside liquidity
or sellside liquidity, this is when I
want to be looking for a continuation.
And the reason for that is if a bearish
setup is going to form, this is where a
bearish setup will form and a bearish
change in the state of delivery. Let's
see if we form a continuation.
And what do we notice? We don't. We're
forming a bearish change in the state of
delivery. And what happens? That's where
we get a move lower. So if we go ahead
and add my indicator back onto this,
right, and we go take a look, you'll
notice this is where it is forming a
bearish setup at a point of interest, a
bearish swing. So that is why I want to
be careful of taking setups when we are
over short-term highs or lows because
that is a lot of time the manipulation
that forms the higher time frame wicks.
So here we are in another example, and
what do we have? We have a nice V-shaped
reversal here. We took out these highs
here. You'd want to see if we form a
continuation. What do we have? A failure
to form a continuation here, right? We
reach into a fair value up. We can't
close over. We sweep out the high. Do
you expect this low to get taken out?
Now, what do we form a continuation
here, right? To see a move higher. Well,
let's see. And what do we notice? We
have a very strong closure through, but
we also have taken out all these highs
here. Now, this doesn't really give me
the best risk-to-reward on a protected
swing. So that's another reason to wait.
Do we form a continuation or do we come
back across the range? Let's give it one
more candle and we come back across the
range aggressively. So this is a good
example of when we run out short-term
highs or the range highs, I want to see
are we going to form a continuation to
break out or is this the manipulation to
trade to the other side of the range. So
in this next example, let's take a look
at this price action here. We had a
little bit of a range. We had a move
lower with a V-shaped recovery. It's not
great. This is quite slow, but we do
have the closure over there. So, I could
be looking for a continuation. We reach
into a fair value gap and we do close
over here. Now, if you remember back to
the PDF, what are we noticing about this
closure here? Well, that would be
scenario two where we're taking out that
short-term high at the same time. And
I'm not just talking about the candle
next to it, right? This is actually a
high. So, there's two things you can do
here. one, if you have enough trust, you
could take this expecting this low to
hold and reach for the highs. Now, what
I personally like to do is I like to
wait and see. Are we going to get a move
lower that takes me out or are we going
to make a swing and trade higher? I
don't know which. So, I prefer to let
this next price action happen and let me
know what is going to occur, right? And
you can see that saves us from a loss
there. And now, if you wanted to trade
it higher, what would you be waiting
for? You know, a nice V-shaped recovery.
and to trade that in the other
direction. You can see we're not getting
that and this is a consolidation. So, as
you can see here, when we run out
short-term highs, depending on how
strong your bias is and how aggressive
you want to be with entries, many times
I wait for another continuation to form.
So, here we are in our next example, and
you can see we have a T-spot in here,
looking for a continuation lower. Let's
see if we can form a continuation. What
do we notice here? price reaches up into
the T-spot area and are we going to form
a continuation? You can see this is
quite a move up. So, we can allow for a
few more candles and this is still a
V-shaped reversal. But what do we notice
about this closure through we are also
taking out this short-term low. So, what
could we wait for? Because this is where
price could form the bullish setup,
right? If we get that, this is why I
want to wait. Does that form or do we
form a new continuation? So, let's see.
Give it a couple candles. We want to see
is this a retracement or a reversal,
right? We want to see a retracement or a
consolidation for continuation. And
let's see, do we get a closure back
through that level? And we do. You can
see how that is a nice V-shaped
reversal. Two candles up. Takes two
candles to come back down. And this is
where we could look to get on side if
we're trading a continuation. You can
see how we get that expansion lower. So,
really pay attention to when we take out
short-term highs and lows. Do we form a
reaction there or do we get a
retracement or a consolidation? In this
next example, we're going to blend
solution one and two together. So, you
can see we have expansion over these
highs. We'd be waiting for a
continuation. Do we get that
continuation? Well, looking at the
series of down close candles, have we
closed over it? Yes. But what do we
notice? We notice that it struggled to
close over and then it also wicked this
high. Not only are we forming a
consolidation, but we've also taken out
a short-term high. This is a very hard
continuation to trust. This is generally
where I want to see a breakout of this
high, right? So, a breakout and a new
continuation to form or this is the
manipulation to run out this low and
then trade that back higher. Let's see
what happens
here. You can see we run out the low. Do
we get this bot back up? Right? We want
to see a nice V-shaped reversal. You can
also use inversions to see that. You can
see we have a nice V-shaped reversal and
that is taking a few candles to close
over. But what do we have? We have
another continuation inside of that with
a nice candle to closure. So the
inversion, you can also use inversions
as a form of the change in the state of
delivery when you have an extremely
large candle range. But that is just an
example of blending those two together.
So here we are in our next example and
you can see we have a nice change in the
state of delivery here respecting this
large wick right here. Now I want to see
if we get a continuation here. And do we
get that? Yes. And you can see how this
is pretty ideal. We reach into a fair
value gap. We have a nice quick closure
over. So I could be looking for this to
make a move higher. As we let this trade
higher, what do we have? We have another
little continuation here. And that's
pretty ideal. Reaching into a fair value
gap. Nice quick closure over and we get
a continuation, right? Those are ideal
scenarios to see. Now, what do we notice
about this? This is where it's starting
to get a bit choppy, right? And it makes
sense at the end of a trend. So what do
we have? We have a consolidation. So
what do we be looking for in a
consolidation? A manipulation, right?
And what do we see? Do we have any
manipulation? No. But let's say for
instance, you were looking at this level
as a continuation, right? Because you're
saying this is a swing. There's no fair
value gaps, nothing below. This should
remain protected. So what would you be
looking for? A quick closure over here.
Not only does it take too long to close
over this level, but it also takes out
our short-term high. So, you can see how
both of those reasons that we are
looking for to avoid continuations are
present. It has a consolidation and it's
also sweeping out. So, when we sweep out
like this, if I do want to trade it,
sure, that's fine. I need to wait for
another continuation. Do we form another
continuation here? No, not before
sweeping out the low. Now, we sweep out
the low. Do we have a continuation that
forms? Well, we want to see if we have a
nice closure through that area.
And what do we have? Price is failing to
close through that area, which usually
means what? It's once again a
consolidation. I'd want to see the low
ran out or what do we have? We can't
close over this level. We can't close
over this level. It's just a
consolidation. Let's see if there's
anything else that happens. And we run
out the low. So, you can see how you can
save yourself some losses by just being
patient and seeing if you get that ideal
continuation. And this is a good example
of this is what ideal continuations look
like. And these are what ideal
continuations do not look like. Even
with this closure here, it's not as
ideal because we're at the highs. We're
taking out highs. We want to see another
continuation form. So, as we continue
this here, you can see we have broken
out of this consolidation. So, I want to
see if we have this consolidation here.
Are we going to manipulate and trade
higher or can we break down? Now, if we
want to trade the breakout of a range,
so this is reason number one with the
consolidation. If we want to trade this
breakout to the downside, what do we
need? We need a continuation. Let's see
if we can form that. We have price trade
higher into a point of interest. Now, if
this is going to form, we want to see a
nice closure through it. And we have. So
now we have this high. We anticipate to
hold. And this is how if you want to
trade a breakout of a consolidation or a
reversal from a consolidation, that's
how you do it. So now we have covered
all of reason number one. When we have a
consolidation, if I want to trade it,
I'm either going to wait for a
manipulation of that consolidation or a
breakout to trade it lower. Now, as we
look for further continuations here,
what are we looking for? Well, we have a
protected high. Is this a retracement or
a consolidation? A consolidation. We
remain internal. So inside this little
consolidation here, what do we want to
see? Do we manipulate this side of the
range to trade lower while respecting
this or do we break out to the upside?
And there you can see we have a nice
candle three closure. But have we formed
this continuation?
Not yet. So let's see if we do form
that. And we do. And here is an example
of what we are breaking out. We are
forming this continuation, but we're
also closing below this. We're taking a
short-term low. If we were taking a
short-term low and we still want to
trade it lower, that's when we want to
wait for another continuation. It's the
same scenario as up here. Here is a
consolidation. We break out lower. We
want to see if we form a continuation.
Here is a consolidation. We break out
lower. Do we form a continuation? Well,
let's see.
So, here you can see we reach into a
fair value gap. We have a nice candle to
closure. Let's see if we can form a
continuation.
No, we cannot. So what is this doing? By
waiting for this continuation, we're not
shorting the lows, right? We're not
getting caught in this price action,
which is actually just a reversal,
right? And so if we let this continue,
you know, we could trade this if we
wanted to, right? Because this is our
protected swing right here, right? It
hasn't been taken. This keeps us from
taking a loss here. We run out the high
and then we trade lower. Once again,
this is a bit more difficult as what are
we doing? We are running lower. We're
taking out short-term lows. So, I'd want
to see a further continuation. And you
can see price comes up, retest that
level, and then we do continue lower.
But that kind of puts all those examples
together, right? If you have a
consolidation, you either wait for a
manipulation or for a breakout. And when
you take out short-term highs or lows
and you're still seeking a continuation,
you want to wait for a continuation move
off of those levels. Now, let's get into
another example. And this is from
someone on Twitter that tagged me in
their post asking why this continuation
failed. So, let's take a look at it. If
you notice here, we do have a nice
V-shaped reversal forming this wick. And
we do have a point of interest, a fair
value gap. So, if we're looking for a
continuation here, what do we want to
see? We want to see a nice quick move
lower, closing below here, and then
continuing lower. Now, if we do take out
this low, we ideally want to see a
closure below it, and then we can wait
for a continuation. So, let's see what
happens.
And what do we notice about this? It
takes one, two, three candles and we're
struggling to close below this level. On
the fourth candle, we take out this low.
So instead of really treating this like
a continuation, I'm more so viewing it
as a consolidation, in which case we run
out this low. So it's not that I'm not
bearish biased anymore. It's just we
have these failure swings here. I want
to see do we form a continuation that I
can trust or are we going to fail and
trade back against the range. Let's see
what happens here. You can see this is
candle 3. You can see we do get the
start of a continuation. I don't like
that we're leaving these failure swings.
But what else do we notice? Even on this
retracement back up, we're struggling or
failing to close below this level. So
there's really no way to trade this for
me. And what do we notice now? Now we
take out the low, we manipulate the low
and we're trading in the other
direction. So now this is bullish to me,
right? And you can see we traded a bit
higher. So the one thing to pick out of
this, and this is for JD on Twitter who
tagged me in his post, is it just takes
too long to form this continuation. Once
we do get the closure, this is now just
a consolidation and we can't really form
a continuation. You can see we never get
the closure below this level. So that is
why I would personally avoid that price
action in there. Now, here we are in our
next example, and this is another one
from someone on Twitter that tagged me
in it wondering why it failed. So, let's
take a look. We do have expansion up and
then I would treat this as a
retracement. Yes. So, I would be looking
for what? A closure through this level.
Do we get that?
Yes. And we have a nice and quick move
through that level. But what do we
notice? We're taking out this high here.
Now, if we add a little more context, I
could be looking for a retracement,
right? just because we've taken out the
high. But now if we go into what my
fractal model actually uses, right? I'm
waiting for this closure on the higher
time frame. So this could simply be
avoided by one, if I'm taking out a high
into my entry, I can give it another
candle or two to see if we're getting a
continuation or if we're coming back
across the range. But also within my
fractal model, I am waiting for this
next candle. This candle has already
expanded and I want to let the next
candle form form its wick and then trade
it away. So, if we give it another
candle here,
you can see, do we form a continuation
out of this fair value gap area here?
No, we do not. And we fall lower. Now,
if I still wanted to trade this, you see
now that we have this candle closure, my
model will print. And then what do we
have? Well, we're sweeping out a low at
a point of interest, right, in a fair
value. Yep. So, I could be looking for
another continuation up here. But, do we
go ahead and get that? Oh, we take out
the low first, right? So now we have a
new series of downclosed candles. I'm
not looking at this anymore. I'm looking
at this one. Do we form a continuation?
We do. And this is a pretty aggressive
move. So I could look to get on side
with that. Or I could also look for
what? Another continuation. Now for me,
if I'm going to be trading this, this is
already the continuation of this
reversal. I haven't taken out any highs.
I can look to get on side with this on
the closure through, put my stop on the
low, and then look for 2 R. Let's see
how that works out.
You see, we almost get stopped out and
then we do end up going right now. One
thing I want to talk about, this is not
ideal structure as well. So, this would
be a bit more of an advanced trade based
off higher time frames, but that is how
I would approach it. I would be focused
on letting the higher time frame wick
form. That's where I'm looking for the
continuation. If you get one thing from
that video, that will probably help you
a lot with your entries. Frame your
entries when it is forming the higher
time frame wick. you're looking for
random continuations. A lot of times
that is going to happen to you. Now, in
our last example here, we have what
looks to be a pretty ideal continuation,
right? We have expansion away,
expansion, a retracement into a fair
value up, and it is bought right back up
and closed over. Let's see if this works
out.
And what do we notice? It fails pretty
hard. So, what would be the reason for
this? Well, let's zoom out to the higher
time frames at this level here. You can
see on NQ here, we just run out all of
these previous highs. I do not want to
be longing after price has already made
it expansion. 1 2 three candles of
expansion and hitting a significant
high. We go back to that on the hourly
chart. This is not the area that I want
to be longing price because that is
where you can get caught up in the new
phase of price. I don't look for
continuations after we've already hit a
higher time frame objective or had
multiple candles of expansion. Now, I
hope this video helps. It's not really
going to make a ton of sense until you
go and do it for yourself. You need to
go into the charts and practice finding
continuations that work and those that
don't that align with your model. Go
back to your journal and see which
trades you could have avoided losses in
if you understood these things. But if
you did enjoy this video, please give it
a like and a subscribe, and I'll see you
guys in the next one. Have a good one.